40 years ago a u.s navy exploratory
vessel landed on a chain of islands in
the south atlantic just 2000 miles off
the coast of argentina in other words
the middle of nowhere yet on this
far-off set of rocks a float in the
middle of the ocean they discovered a
vast array of strange wildlife and plant
species that resemble little of what
they left behind on the mainland could
this be a treasure trove of undiscovered
species they wondered hoping to
capitalize on the discovery a
reconnaissance team of researchers was
sent out to explore some of the islands
on foot and what they found did not
disappoint from endangered species of
birds to plant life and vegetation that
looked like it belonged on mars they
found a dizzying array of new and
exciting examples of evolutionary
oddities that would fill a library but
unfortunately their jubilation was cut
short attempting to collect soil samples
they dug into the ground and soon
discovered that what they were standing
on wasn't actually ground at all the
navy scientists soon discovered the
rocky terrain they were exploring was
actually made up entirely of organic
matter as per the standard protocol the
scp foundation was forced to silence the
u.s navy research vessel after its
discovery with the ok from the u.s
government the ship was torpedoed and
sunk to the bottom of the ocean with all
hands on deck in the name of protecting
the greater good of the masses a tragedy
at sea for the sake of preventing
worldwide pandemonium from there the
foundation took over with the
containment procedures of what would
eventually come to be known as scp-169
known by its nickname the leviathan the
leviathan is a biblical creature of
mythical proportions said to be able to
boil the seas and create earth-ending
floods with just a whip of its massive
continent-spanning body it is unclear if
scp-169 has the ability to do these
things though given its massive size
which foundation researchers estimate to
be somewhere between two thousand and
eight thousand kilometers it's easy to
see how something that big moving at any
speed could be devastating for the
coastal regions of the world although we
use the word contain it is impossible
for scp staff to ever contain something
of such massive size surveillance and
monitoring are about all we can do for
now that and hope it never wakes up and
decides that we're on the menu it was
thought to be relatively smooth sailing
until one incident changed everything dr
hart turned off the video monitor and
faced the assembled members of mtf gamma
6 also known as the deep feeders
renowned for their specialization in the
tracking of deep sea and oceanic
anomalies the room was dark and each
team member was sitting in shadow but
still dr hart could see the seriousness
on their faces i'm sure you're wondering
why i called you here at such short
notice he said on the screen behind him
he put up a nasa satellite picture of a
small set of rocky islands you see this
little island chain here well it wasn't
there a week ago he paused rubbing his
forehead from lack of sleep at 8 05 am
today we recorded another auditory
anomaly emitting from
scp-169 this one was much louder and
longer than the one recorded in 1997 by
the national oceanic and atmospheric
administration the one known as the
bloop back then it was easy to brush off
as some ice breaking off of a
continental shelf and scraping against
the sea floor it's not so easy to cover
up anymore these auditory emissions from
scp-169 are beginning to grow more
frequent more than that increased
seismic activity around the archipelago
on the creature's back indicates that
the rate at which the creature is
breathing is also up typically the rate
at which the creature takes what we are
assuming to be a breath is once every
three months the rate has increased to
once every three weeks for as long as
we've been monitoring scp-169 it's been
a drift along the southern atlantic
never moving more than a kilometer a
week that behavior is slowly beginning
to change it doesn't sound like much but
something that big even moving just a
fraction of that faster means 100-foot
tidal waves for the entire south
american coastline we fear the creature
showing signs of waking up if this is
true it could mean a cataclysm for the
hundreds of nations around the world
millions hell even billions could be
wiped off the face of the earth if this
thing just flips its body too fast in
the wrong direction to put it to scale
this monster is about the size of the
caribbean maybe even bigger as far as we
know the doctor then pulled out a
decanter of whiskey and poured himself a
glass swallowing the entire pore in one
go in an appalling breach of workplace
professionalism seriously an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario is still no
excuse for drinking on the job we're
talking about an extinction level event
a bona fide xk class end of the world
scenario 1000 foot tsunami wave
stretching as far as the eye can see
from either end of the horizon the last
time scp-169 stirred it created the
mediterranean in fact the legends of the
biblical flood noah's ark the same story
can be found in every civilization and
culture around the world so maybe they
were on to something it is to this end i
call you all here to save the world from
the next great flood he paused for a
moment as the room took in the gravity
of the situation the more we can learn
about
scp-169 the better right now we know
squat for one we've never seen just how
deep the body of the creature goes or
what's under it the pressure has been
too great for our current model
submarines until now after reinforcing
our nema 1 deep sea submersible with
thamaturtical runes the integrity of its
hull has increased exponentially your
mission will be to travel as far down
and as close to the creature as possible
if it breathes then there must be gills
or lungs there must be some basic
biological facts we need to understand
if we're going to survive extinction our
only recourse is to find a way to sedate
the creature and if that doesn't work
then
god help us all just 12 hours later deep
in the waters of the southern atlantic a
massive submersible ship was diving down
into the depths of the deep ocean
looking for a way to stop the end of the
world agent just 6-1 a member of deep
feeders looked out of the massive
viewing port as the ship slowly
descended alongside the rocky trench
that made up the body of scp-169
behind him was dr hart sporting a white
five o'clock shadow and a red nose from
a night of drinking to calm his nerves
the entire crew were silent in awe as
the giant floodlights of the ship
brushed over the barnacle-covered
surfaces of the undersea mountain they
progressed slowly breaching each
milestone in depth with caution knowing
that one wrong move could destabilize
the pressure in their ship just 6-1
murmured the word scales what asked dr
hart i've been watching the patterns of
the ridges as we sink down they look
like scales giant segments it's hard to
see at first because they're so covered
in barnacles and sediment but i'm sure
of it they're giant armored scales the
way lobsters or crabs have armored
exoskeletons interesting the doctor said
scratching his chin arthropods have
segmented armored bodies this means we
might be looking at some sort of
evolutionary hybrid some sort of aquatic
mammal such as a whale or dolphin one
that has developed armored segmented
scales similar to that of a crustacean
the doctor crossed his arms to think the
closest thing we have on the fossil
record of this magnitude is an armored
fish from the cretaceous period but even
that's way too small to compare to this
this thing has an entire ecosystem on
its back how old is it ask the agent
well now that you mention it given the
impossible age of the creature an
arthropod would make sense lobsters and
other crustaceans don't age
conventionally you see they are
effectively immortal in fact they
actually die because they continue to
grow until their bodies can't hold up
their humongous size anymore and yet
scp-169 just kept growing the doctor
trailed off thinking to himself dr hart
still lost in thought turned to walk to
the back of the submersible as jus 6-1
followed he said as much to himself as
to the agent the creature is old the
geological survey conducted when scp-169
was first discovered carbon dated the
specimen to over 541 million years old
as you can probably surmise that's too
old for any living being the results had
to be incorrect and yet i checked them
myself more than once and numbers do not
lie the entity predates our civilization
hell it predates complex life forms on
this planet as we know it from an
evolutionary standpoint it doesn't make
any sense the agent confused asked
doctor how could something so big even
come into existence very little of our
planet is actually land mass it's a
wonder we call it earth most of this
planet is water we aren't looking at a
creature that's on our planet agent we
are on each planet just then a flurry of
alarms and sensors began to go off at
the bridge of the ship the team
scrambled through their stations
checking off monitors and shouting
readings to each other the ship's
thermal sensors are detecting a massive
rise in temperature transmitting power
to cooling systems we have activity
northwest of our location sonar has
something big headed our way we need to
dive now the ship lurched forward nose
first as everyone on board held onto
their seats the restraints keeping them
from falling forward just outside of the
viewing port dr hart could see an
enormous scaled appendage moving fast in
their location we need to steer the ship
clear of the talons revert all power to
the thrusters get us out of the way the
doctor yelled don't you think i'm doing
that the captain shouted back the ship
jolted sideways and downwards as an
immense wave of pressure came over the
submersible putting six g's of force on
its occupants just 6-1 yelped out of
fear as the ship came close to crashing
into what appeared to be the edge of a
titanic talon the size of the empire
state building following the encounter
the part of the ship bordering the
reinforced glass of the viewing port
began to glow bright red it's boiling
the water around us one of the crew
members cried out it's not boiling
anything it's just cavitation due to the
pressure reduction in the water the
updated runes on the ship's hull should
keep us safe we just need to cool our
heads stay focused on the mission bottom
feeders after several moments of holding
their breaths the crew of nemo one began
to relax as their pace returned to a
slow descent along the side of the
underwater behemoth before long the
vessel was no longer traveling straight
down but starting to curve under the
creature traveling north towards the
theoretical head of
scp-169 after several hours the ship
came upon giant fissures in the rocky
exterior of the creature these massive
vent-like structures appeared stiff but
slowly they opened and closed over the
span of weeks these were the respiratory
organs of the organism clocking in at
over two miles underneath the surface of
the ocean the crew carefully began
entering the smaller pod-like
submersibles that detach from their main
ship just 6-1 entered his pod and
strapped on the haptic gloves that would
give him control of the pod's robotic
arms he and a team of three other
volunteers had agreed to undergo the
dangerous mission of attaching
artificial chemical emission machines
that could be programmed to release
anesthetic gas into
scp-169's respiratory system on command
remotely the emission machines could be
refueled manually whenever the contents
ran out it was an ingenious solution dr
hart came up with when thinking of his
time studying sharks as a marine
biologist it would tag the fins of
sharks by capturing them and bringing
the specimens on the deck of their boat
from there the scientists would drill a
radio frequency emitter onto the fin of
the shark when he had first seen this
practice as a young college student dr
hart was afraid the process was harming
the shark but later he learned it was
designed in a way to not be harmful to
the specimen and eventually the tag
would fall off after enough data on the
shark's movement was collected except
these tags would not be falling off he
thought they could not for the sake of
all mankind this had to work the doctor
pressed a button on the receiver of the
radio and spoke just 6-1 what's your
status pressure's whole thing all signs
look good just 6-2 precious holding all
good just 6-3 all clear captain joe 6-4
there is silence just six dash for do
you copy
all clear doc sorry my mic was muted on
route and ready to do this thing dr hart
sighted relief and slowly reclined in
this chair watching the pods move closer
to the large openings on
scp-169 side one by one the robotic arms
used underwater torches to drill into
the thick rock-like exoskeleton of the
creature screwing in complex
million-dollar equipment that was both
waterproof and could withstand the
immense pressure at such a depth under
the ocean as the minutes turned to hours
dr hart couldn't help but feel anxiety
for the safety of his crew and the
success of the mission but before long
the pods began to return one by one to
the mother craft each completing the
segment of work with which they were
tasked the last pod still working was
just 6-1 whose robotic arm was in the
process of rotating a large industrial
size screw just 6-1 had all but finished
when suddenly a low rumble could be felt
shaking the larger submersible dr hart's
voice came crackling over the radio get
back to the ship now just 6-1 wrapped in
deep focus on this task replied i'm just
about finished just packing up my tool
belt leave it return to the ship now
that's an order jesus what's wrong it's
not like this is the end of the world
said the agent chuckling over his radio
an ear-piercing echo sent shockwaves
through the depths of the ocean around
the submersible the waves rumbled with
the sound of
scp-169's voice similar to the sound of
a large whale but amplified by a million
the sound sent all the crew members
falling to the floor as the ship
experienced severe damage from the burst
of pressure slightly cracking the glass
viewport and sending smoke flooding into
the small bridge of the ship gas masks
shout out dr hart as they all don
breathing apparatus
scp-169 is waking up begin activation of
the chemical emission machines we need
to sedate it now the leviathan is waking
up we need to stop it shouted dr hart
just then he looked back and noticed
just 6-1 pod was gone just 6-1 what's
your position just 6-1 where are you sir
sona has him drifting off deeper into
the ocean behind us he must have gotten
knocked off as cp 169 by the shockwave
but dr hart wouldn't have it he didn't
want any more blood on his hands reverse
thrusters turn us around and get to him
we're not losing anyone but the breach
in the hull little home that's what the
runes are for the outside of the
submersible began to glow a slight blue
as the ship's system started to come
back online to full capacity and alarm
systems started to turn off and report
normal pressure readings before long the
nemo one had caught up to just 6-1's pod
and retrieved the agent who had been
knocked unconscious by the shock wave
once the agent was back on the main ship
the doctor turned his attention back to
the monitors making sure the
installations they drilled into the
creature were functional slowly the
machines came online to full power and
the speed at which
scp-169 had been moving began to slow
ever so slightly the team all watched
the viewport in silence as a steady
stream of anesthetic gas was pumped into
the respiratory system of the gigantic
living myth in front of them after a few
moments of waiting the doctor spoke i
think it worked he said with a smile the
crew erupted in cheers as they radioed
control back up on land that the mission
had been a success the message quickly
reached the o5 council where a red alert
status was de-escalated and the o5
members withdrew from their plan of
leaving the current earth for that of an
alternate universe the whole crew began
to sing and celebrate the prevention of
the end of the world as dr hart simply
stood in front of the massive viewport
watching the mountainous specimens
slowly grow smaller in the distance as
the submersible began ascending back to
the world above just 6-1 came over to
congratulate him patting him on the back
we did it he said loosen up the doctor
managed to laugh along in acknowledgment
that we did he said relief that we did
the two watched the deep blue ocean in
silence taking in the vastness of the
sea perhaps this would not be the end of
it but that day they had done what the
scp foundation did best kick that
apocalyptic can a few miles down the
road and sometimes in the face of the
terrifying and the infinite that's
really the best you can do now go check
out scp-3000 anita shisha and
scp-2316 the bodies in the water for
more frightening aquatic anomalies